something that's been a trend in sports
the last couple years
guys with these cryptic messages on
instagram and twitter it's bizarre
kyrie's been known to do them
my guy carmelo anthony i love him he
drops some words of wisdom every once in
a while you pointed out the michael
thomas tweet the other day thomas
yesterday jesus very cryptic tweet from
michael thomas also an instagram post so
i thought who better to speak on this
issue than bhumani jones because bhumani
jones one of the great voices in all
sports media and i know he's very
passionate about the subject of
people
posting on instagram without using
photos what are your thoughts on michael
thomas bomani
all i'm saying about all these people is
you tell me if i'm tripping like you let
me know if i'm wrong
how many people that you see that always
post all these words on instagram how
many of them do you ever ask for advice
right like
something about this era has led people
to believe that people need advice from
them right like no matter what
somebody's out there listening they
believe that somebody needs to hear from
them and i just want to know who ever
asked them what they thought in the
first place like any of the people that
i would ask them what they thought they
don't just give the stuff away they just
don't
well bonnie if you're an assistant coach
in new orleans and you bring this to the
attention to sean payton what's sean
payton's reaction
here's the one thing though they know
this dude right like none of them are
surprised by this being a thing that's
happened and he seems to be a dude
people on his own team and on his other
team kind of struggle to like him like i
imagine that there's some people who do
don't get me wrong like i don't act like
nobody in the world likes for the
percentage of people that seem to
dislike michael thomas is higher than
the average so this has happened i don't
know what actually went down that's the
one thing i do want to be fair about but
that's michael thomas's fault at this
point he is welcome to let us know how
he was protecting them why are you still
protecting them if it's like this
well monty jones joins the show the
right time with bomani jones when he
comes to football this time of year what
gets you really fired up is it a trade
lands pass in practice is it the fact
that we're hearing carson wentz is
planning to be the week one starter
despite the foot injury what gets you
fired up for football this time of year
oh absolutely nothing like it'll be here
with this time of year it would be
different if i didn't work in this right
like at some point i get to chill at
some point i get to relax we just had
the nba finals like three weeks ago or
something like that so like yeah i think
i do enjoy a good hold out i will admit
that like that probably seems
counterintuitive to this but i do like
watching the back and forth of a hold
out far more than anything else that
could happen at a preseason game been a
fan of your work for a long time now i
get to associate you with being a big
hold out guy yeah you know that bomani
he's always rooting for hold outs i love
that uh you're also a sneaker expert and
our buddy tj jefferson had a little
trouble with an old pair of air jordans
yeah pulled them out of the closet they
were about eight nine years old and the
soul fell off they were older than that
bo i just had the repair of high top
jordan twos i probably hadn't worn them
in about five years
put them on yesterday
soul ripped right off them quentin
richardson came on the show and
suggested that tj build a wine cellar in
his home or to preserve the shoes not
realizing that tj's the social media
producer at the rich eisen show and wine
cellar not really in the equation what
do you do to preserve all your shoes i
know you're a big sneaker head
yeah honestly never mind i really own
enough to where i got to worry so much
about preserving them i think if it
really gets to a point where you got to
think about how to keep them up that
long you might want to consider those
things like i just did a donation of a
whole bunch of shoes because i lived in
new york and i moved to a smaller place
so i had to make that happen i will note
though that they were jordan too you
don't hear people get too emotionally
attached to george jews very often i
make a comparison that doesn't have a
whole lot of venn diagram overlap for
people who care but the jordan 2 are
basically the equivalent of the led
zeppelin 3.
like like it's people out there who
really really love it but in comparison
to everything else on the run instead of
a skipper
well money i got really excited this
morning uh just as a fan of basketball
and great stories the idea of russell
westbrook coming home to los angeles
we'll analyze the turnovers and the
three-pointers and the shot selection
later but for right now just the idea of
this kid was a fan of the lakers lost
his friend growing up played for ucla
stayed in la now he's getting a chance
to come home i think it's a great story
what are your thoughts on russ coming
home to the lakers
yeah i'm a big russell westbrook fan
right like he's just a person where i
like his get down like way he handles
things by and large i liken the stories
that you hear about them that don't you
know come out nearly as much about just
kind of being just a good dude um i rock
with him on this i have no idea how this
is going to work as a basketball thing
none whatsoever um i i'm inclined to
think that it's not simply that his best
days are past us but i think that like i
don't even know how good the next days
are going to wind up being but what i do
want to see we've never seen him asked
to play a role quite as secondary as
what they're going to ask him to play
here like even with the rockets
they did a lot of staggering with him
and harden so russell still had like a
30 usage rate and with washington even
with bradfield there he still put up a
grip a shot he's a clear number three
here in best case scenario and so i'm
wondering how he's going to wind up
adapting to that because say what you
want about russell westbrook i do
believe that he is willing to make
certain alterations to do what is
necessary to win i think he really
believe all that other stuff is going to
help him win even the things that we
wound up complaining about i don't think
he'll be able to look himself in the
face and say that about how he fits on
this roster
the right time with bomani jones podcast
is the podcast bomani joins us right now
ben line's in for rich on the rich eisen
show we stay in los angeles to talk some
clippers tj a huge kawhi fan i don't get
it bomani i don't know how you can be
the best player in a team and be so
aloof and so difficult to get a read on
and set the tone for the rest of the
organization where do you stand on kauai
you ever seen a guy behave like this in
the nba
i don't even know how anybody can like
say how they stand on him because he
ain't giving us nothing to base his
information on other than really actual
play i'm with you i've never seen
anything quite like this and the one
thing i do say about him is you we all
get to have the personality type that we
have and teams have been willing to work
around the personality that he does have
but
i don't think it is appropriate to flex
on the perks of being the star of the
team if you don't want to do the
uncomfortable parts of being the star on
the team so like if you want to have it
where you're showing up late all the
time and everybody's operating on your
schedule okay that's cool but to me that
means you got to be the dude that's all
around that does all that leader guy
stuff that we think is kind of cliche in
sports but all of it does have a value
so like that's that's the one thing i do
say about him be who you want to be but
if you want to be the man and get all
the perks of it then you also have to
deal with what some of the costs are
well monty brockman's having a tough
time because he loves your podcast he
listens every morning to work but over
the last two weeks we've now kind of
flip-flopped we we're trading places
here we've switched i now have cardiac
kemba playing at the world's most famous
i got evan fournier fresh off his france
run to silver medal he's dealing with
dennis schroeder now it's like the
knicks and celtics have have twisted
fates and have switched sides now
brockman's spiraling what's happening in
boston
well i mean you can get shooter for six
million dollars that's a steal right
like i think they're real questions to
have about
kemba walker and his knees and how
they're gonna hold up and i don't know
how you take your bad d to go play for
this tip that's just not something that
i personally would wind up doing but
chas palm and terry did a voiceover on a
video bomani it's gonna be fine
hey man i'm glad especially living in
new york now like i'm glad that the next
is something to talk about because it
seemed to make people really happy just
as they were up like i like to see the
people around us happy and they really
really seem to be thrilled about the
fact that they were back to some measure
of uh basketball relevance but
everything i think getting schruter for
the price that they got him at i think
that that's a win like that dude
apparently made one of the worst
decisions anybody's ever made and i just
want to know what information he had
when he turned down the 20 million a
year extension what led him to believe
that things are going to be better and
what changed to the point where he's
taking a one-year deal for six million
bucks and what makes you think bulmani
that a one-year dennis shooter who's
trying to prove himself to get a
long-term deal that he missed out on is
a good situation for boston dennis
playing for himself yeah sign me up for
that yeah but see i don't feel like a
one-year dennis shooter is that much
different than a four-year different
shooter like what he get what he gives
you is a mean first step right he's got
the ball he can get by you on the first
step that's what his career has been the
whole way now how you figure out how to
work that best is its own thing but it's
a dude that can get to the basket that
can get his own shot and you can't have
too many of those in the nba
the right time with bomani
with bomani jones is the podcast talk to
me about this bob costas opportunity
you're hanging out with one of one of
the legends in this business
you know the show is back on the record
with bob costas um we're going to have
an episode on the last weeks of august
september and october for this year that
is going to be quarterly um for 2022 and
i just got a call out of nowhere bob
wants to talk to me and he mentioned
what the show was that he wanted to have
my voice to make contributions on it and
i was like yeah i'll do that okay
you know and so i do an essay and i
participate in the panel on each episode
the next episode is august the 27th
uh speaking of uh your essays you your
podcast this week you did one on
the complicated ending of bobby bowden's
life can you just
kind of give our listeners the reader's
digest of your take there i thought it
was really interesting
yeah i think that bobby
he's a charming man like number one he's
a charming man from an era
where
coaches had personalities like that's
something that doesn't really happen
right now the job has become much more
corporate at this point and these guys
just really aren't much fun in any sort
of way bobby bowden always was and is
the rare guy who rose to providence
while doing very public losing like they
finished in the top five 14 times in a
row but they had five different seasons
where miami was their only regular
season lost and we saw that right like
that rivalry is the premier college
football robbery of the 1990s and so
there's an affection that a lot of us
have for bobby bow because he just
seemed like a guy that would like
whoever it was that he was talking to
because he's that guy and he's the guy
who kind of get away with saying
inappropriate things just because you
like him so much but on the way out
well not on the way out i don't think
that's the best way to put it but he had
coveted last year
and he recovered in his 90s and put out
a statement that said that uh he was
glad that he recovered because he wanted
to live long enough to vote for donald
trump and i feel like when you say
something like that in public in 90
years old you have decided how you want
us to remember you like you wanted to
make sure that you had that on the books
before you died and
who am i to remember him other than the
way that he wished
that's interesting bomani because it
makes me think about the larger
conversation sports fans are having with
the athletes and coaches they root for
there's more of a transparency now as a
sports fan not only do you want your
favorite coaches and players to succeed
but oftentimes you want them to feel the
same as you politically to stand up for
issues that you believe in to have
investments in companies that you
support it's a lot that we put on these
these men and women and it's a different
time in the sports fan
player coach relationship and the point
you're making about bobby bowen the way
he wanted to be remembered what other
choice do we have as sports fans to
remember him that way and then infer
whatever we take away from that so where
do you think the sort of the line draws
with how much we can kind of poke and
pry into the personal lives and personal
beliefs of these men and women
well i think that there's a difference
between asking people to agree with you
politically and preferring that those
that you pay homage to
not believe support and endorse things
that are somewhere between offensive and
destructive
um that i don't think is actually
anything new uh think about this case in
point i think it's in
1983 that lou holtz gets fired at
arkansas because he filmed a campaign ad
for jesse helms from his office
now keep in mind this is in the state of
arkansas in
1983
and that got him fired okay and that's
not just simply because like
that is not something that was done
simply because people disagree with
jesse helms i bet he polled very well
arkansas was out of state but you
understand the point that i'm making
that these things have come up all the
time and we've had them come up at many
times that without i am a black dude
from the south so this lands a little
bit different for me because
people who grew up in the age range
generation that i did which is coming
after the beginning of some dawn of
integration you come across dudes like
bobby bowden all the time and they treat
you really really good they're very nice
they charm your mama
everything else but giving your
knowledge of the prevailing views of the
area that you're in you can't help but
wonder to some degree what this guy
maybe not thinks about you but what he
would think about you if you were not
you if that makes sense and there's a
particular sort of heartbreak that can
come up when you're that person and you
hear somebody endorse something or push
something that is not just something you
disagree with but something that is in
opposition to things that are
fundamental to your being
i think throughout time and across the
board no matter who the people are they
have made decisions about who they are
going to root for and not root for based
on those sorts of things and so i don't
think that part is really anything new i
think the part that's new is that you
have much more chatter about it on
things like social media and so you wind
up hearing people say a lot of things
out loud and it will be amplified but
then in the end if whoever that person
is winds up winning and nobody cares we
just saw this happen with kanye west
think about all the things you heard
people say about how done they were with
kanye west and he put all them people up
in a stadium in the midst of the delta
variant to go listen to an album he
wouldn't even finish with
the album's about to come out it's
almost perfect though bomani he's
waiting for it to be just right you got
to get it just right i appreciate you
taking some time the right time podcast
with bomani jones lastly i want to leave
you with this you know we just had
executive director of the wnbpa terry
jackson come on the other day and talked
about this new commissioner's cup the
wnba has kicking off on thursday night
and you saw team usa get their seventh
gold medal in a row filled with huge
stars in the w coming back for the
second half of the season what do you
make of the the cultural moment that the
wa seems to be experiencing right now
where it seems like for the first time
in my lifetime there's a laundry list of
players who are really active in the
cultural space society you can feel
their presence on social media what do
you make for the second half of the wnba
season and what's happening in that
sport well the big thing that's happened
is the basketball is really good
um
and i had never watched a whole lot of
wnba basketball but i did watch kind of
at the dawn of the sport a little bit
more as it went along and the quality of
play that we have now is just so much
higher than it was before and i also
think that with social media where it's
really helped the wnba
is i understand everyone who says that
they want to see more prominent coverage
of wnba like on espn all sports center
and so forth and so on right
i totally get that but on sportscenter
for example it was a one-hour episode of
sportscenter they only got one hour and
they have to figure out how to allocate
that hour and that's largely based on
what the metrics are that say that
people are interested in something right
like there aren't that many things that
people are putting on television or in a
broadcast medium just to do a favor
somebody right like this is not public
broadcasting that's typically not how it
works
something like women's basketball can
really win on social media though
because you get a lot more people who
have the option of opting in themselves
and a lot more people who can share the
content with people that would not
ordinarily get it so if i follow
somebody who for whatever reason i'm
into what they're talking about and i
have a measure of trust with them
they if they are wnba fans are then
going to talk about the wnba and they're
going to talk about women's basketball
and you're going to be able to reach
some people that you just wouldn't have
gotten otherwise in large part because
they're going to sign up for
what the person who is putting it out
there is doing they trust that person
and so if i were to get on for example
and start talking about the wnba they're
going to be people who ordinarily would
not have watched it that are going to be
like look i don't think bulma would
steer me wrong about this i'm going to
check it out and now you get more people
who are into it and more people who are
talking about it and you're not bound by
the finite resources of more gatekeeping
type of operations who have to figure
out what they're going to give their
precious time to
appreciate the insights as always huge
fan of your work love the podcast and uh
really appreciate you taking some time
man touch on a lot of different stuff
all right no problem man you guys have a
good day romani jones joining the show
the right time podcast
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here